estamos de regreso para conocer cuáles
son las principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y para eso nos acompaña jorge
hurtado porque vamos a comenzar con
noticias de la región nos vamos a ir
hasta argentina donde el banco central
aumentó su tasa de interés de referencia
así de santiago y es que la decisión se
da a tres semanas después de que el
gobierno acordara o anunciar un
principio de acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional para refinanciar
esta multimillonaria deuda que tiene
argentina este sería el segundo aumento
en lo que va del año la tasa de interés
de referencia pasa del 40 al 42,5 por
ciento anual la subida es de 250 puntos
básicos el organismo pidió que los tipos
de interés en argentina deben superar la
inflación interanual que actualmente se
sitúa en el 51 por ciento el banco
central elevó también los mínimos de las
tasas de interés sobre los plazos fijos
para personas físicas la tasa mínima
será del 41 5% anual mientras que para
el resto de depositantes se situará en
el
39,5 por ciento del gobierno alberto
fernández todavía cumple las exigencias
para conseguir la refinanciación del
préstamo
40.000 millones de dólares de los cuales
ya había dicho anteriormente que no
tenía argentinas la capacidad de
pagarlos así es bueno jorge bueno
argentinas vamos ahora hasta mexico de
los productores de aguacate así están
gustando los días y las horas para poder
exportar nuevamente verdad así es y
bueno al parecer esta suspensión podría
terminar en los próximos días así lo
dijo el gobernador de michoacán alfredo
ramírez bedolla quien mantiene
conversaciones con eeuu para restablecer
la exportación el 12 de febrero el
servicio de inspección sanitaria de
plantas y animales del departamento de
agricultura americano notificó a mexico
la suspensión temporal de la exportación
de aguacate de michoacán esto luego de
que van a del crimen organizado que
operan en la zona amenazaran a uno de
sus inspectores el aguacate es el tercer
producto de exportación más importante
para méxico según datos del grupo
consultor de mercados agrícolas las
exportaciones de aguacates a eeuu
generaron unos 2800 millones de dólares
en 2021 así como 300 mil empleos entre
directos e indirectos
vamos a hablar ahora a jorge de la
reunión de líderes del g20 de verdad que
ya comenzó en indonesia contanos que van
a abordar así bueno sin duda entre los
temas principales será la pandemia y
también el conflicto que se vive en
europa del este con rusia y ucrania esta
reunión se produce un momento en el que
muchas economías sufren el aumento de
los precios y los bancos centrales
buscan subir los tipos de interés para
enfriar la inflación los ministros de
finanzas y los gobernadores de los
bancos centrales de los países del g20
se reunirán por dos días y las tensiones
entre rusia y ucrania se muestran como
un factor para frenar la recuperación
económica según han dicho el ministro de
finanzas de indonesia sir mulyani
insistió en la necesidad de coordinación
entre los países que se encuentran en
diferentes etapas de recuperación
económica vamos a hablar ahora de egipto
que están ampliando una parte de lo que
es el canal de su es verdad así es y
bueno esta ampliación se da justamente
donde el año pasado el gigantesco
portacontenedores llamado ever giving
quedo
y bloqueo ese canal durante seis días
afectando el comercio mundial luego del
incidente las autoridades egipcias han
estado trabajando en la elaboración de
planes para evitar que se repitan este
tipo de accidentes la ampliación busca
hacer accesibles al tráfico
bidireccional 10 kilómetros adicionales
esto permitiría que los barcos naveguen
en ambos sentidos las autoridades del
canal de suez se están ampliando la vía
de agua en 40 metros para hacerlas de
240 metros de ancho el proyecto se
ejecuta con equipos de mano de obra
egipcio lo que hará que el costo del
proyecto se reduzca en unos 192 millones
de dólares el canal el canal de suez es
una de las vías marítimas más
importantes del mundo tiene 162
kilómetros de longitud por los que se
navegan mayoritariamente en una sola
dirección solamente 72 kilómetros del
tramo son en doble sentido bueno jorge
vamos con los indicadores de la jornada
que nos dicen bueno arrancamos con wall
street que cerró en negativo y su
principal indicador tuvo su peor sesión
del 2020 por el nuevo aumento de
tensiones entre estados y rusia en
europa el efecto de negatividad dejo en
rojo los indicadores también temerosos
por una posible invasión rusa en ucrania
y ese efecto de este conflicto llegó a
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
interrumpió siete sesiones consecutivas
de ganancias y se realidad hoy con
pérdidas gracias jorge por esta nueva
crónica hasta aquí la información
económica en france 24 los invitamos a
seguir informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]